what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some brand new details about
Marvel's what if season 2 and I got to
say I think I like these story ideas
better than the first season I am more
intrigued about what these stories could
be overall more than I was with the
first season now we have official titles
for every episode Marvel Studios has
officially released them also some
insiders have come out given us some run
times for a few of the episodes we also
have some Insider details about a very
specific specific Avengers episode that
is going to be coming in Marvel's what
if so a lot to unpack today if you are
excited for Marvel Studios what if let
us know in the comments down below and
after you hear the title of all of the
episodes let us know which one you are
most excited for right away I think
after seeing all the episode title names
I think I'm excited for episode two
which is titled what if Peter Quill
attacked Earth's Mightiest Heroes that's
mine after you hear them let us know
yours in the comments down below and and
don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment on the video because you're
automatically entered in our giveaway if
you do for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month so we know some
pretty big details about some of these
episodes that are listed and of course
we'll just start in order the first one
listed is episode one what if nebula
joined the Nova cor and some of these
just by the title you can't exactly tell
what the specific story is going to be
they're left to be pretty vague of
course that way they Capt your interest
and make you watch them but for episode
one of season 2 what if nebula joined
the novacore this is what happens it's a
world where Ronan Ronin the accuser from
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 1 deposes
Thanos who is of course nebula's dad
long before the events of Avengers
Infinity War so now nebula essentially
kind of being free she is desperate to
escape her father's Shadow and she sets
out to prove her detective chops now now
admittingly I wasn't the biggest fan of
Marvel's what if season 1 but I am
looking forward to season 2 I hope I
enjoy it more because I do like the idea
of one event completely changing
somebody's life so instead of ronin
losing to the Guardians of the Galaxy he
ultimately defeats Thanos which makes
nebula free that is just one event that
completely changes her life she would go
on to be mean but eventually soften up a
little bit to her sister and the
Guardians they become her family but it
looks like in this scenario this one
incident where Ronin essentially frees
her kind of makes her flip a switch
right away Thanos is no longer there she
can do what she wants no revenge on her
sister no family with the guardians but
instead becomes a member of the Nova
Corb it's a pretty cool premise I really
like it I really like the premise of the
second episode as well what if Peter
Quill attacked Earth's Mightiest Heroes
now again this title is vague but we
know what the premise for this episode
is going to be and despite Peter Quill
being in the the title it's not really
about the Guardians of the Galaxy this
is not the Guardians versus The Avengers
but it's actually about Peter Quill
being delivered to Ego as a kid yandu
actually delivered him as opposed to
what actually happened in the MCU where
he did not deliver him to Ego so in this
episode ego does get his son Peter Quill
who we know is part Celestial and ego
and Peter go to Earth causing the
Earth's Mightiest Heroes of 1988 to
assemble and as far as we know the
Avengers are going to be Hank Pim the
original Ant-Man king T Chaka who is the
current Black Panther the Winter Soldier
Wendy Lawson StarForce and Thor and
reportedly Peggy Carter will be the
director of shield and Howard Stark will
also make an appearance so as you might
have seen episode one is going to come
out December 22nd episode 2 What If
Peter Quill attacked Earth's Mightiest
Heroes comes out December 23rd and
December 24th Christmas Eve is a very
fitting episode episode three what if
happy Hogan Saved Christmas and this one
is a really cool idea because it's
basically kind of a DI hard episode
where happy Hogan is mlan it's an
Avengers party at the Avengers Tower
it's the annual holiday party happy and
Darcy are actually in charge of it Darcy
is interning there but Justin Hammer
lays Siege to The Avengers Tower forcing
happy Hogan to step up and become a hero
now of course the other Avengers are
there and happy is asking for help but
they kind of were just like oh we'll
catch you at the party Happy kind of
just wanting to enjoy the party which
force is happy to step up and become the
holiday party hero and I like this I
think it's a great concept I think it's
fun and it's a holiday themed one at the
perfect time now we know a little bit
more about the rest but first big thank
you to fume for sponsoring this
video fume is a GameChanger for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit and
that's exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's
trfu m.com and use code Cosmic to save
an additional 10% off your order today
then we have episode four what if Iron
Man crashed into The Grandmaster coming
out December 25th on Christmas day now
it's interesting is this was actually
supposed to be a part of season 1
obviously it wasn't now it is a part of
season 2 and from what we've seen in the
trailers Iron Man will land on sakar and
he will be forced to compete in the
grand Masters games going up against
Valkyrie this will definitely be a cool
switch and probably a really fun episode
to watch then we have episode five
coming out December 26th what if Captain
Carter fought the Hydra stomper and this
could be kind of a continuation of some
of the events that took place in season
one of course where Peggy Carter became
Captain Carter instead of Steve Rogers
becoming Captain America then we have
what if Episode 6 dropping December 27th
which is going to be a really cool
episode introducing a new Marvel
character what if kahori reshaped the
world kahori is a brand new character
created specifically for this series and
maybe will even go on to become a
live-action character the episode will
ask the question what would happen if
the Tesseract fell to Earth and landed
in The Sovereign hadu Nani Confederacy
before the colonization of America which
is really cool and this means a lot to a
lot of people I know so I'm really
excited to see this new character and
this episode I'm also really looking
forward to the next one episode 7 which
comes out December 28th what if Hela
found the 10 rings in this episode we
will see Hela get kicked out of asgar
like Thor and Ragnarok but instead of
being imprisoned in hell she finds
herself accepted by Tallow and their
inhabitants learning their martial arts
Odin will invade Tallow and war between
as Asgard and tala will break out hela's
armor will be all white instead of black
and green and who knows maybe she even
knows Shan Chi's mother Jang Lee really
looking forward to this one cuz I think
Hela was a great character and I'm glad
she's not all gone yet then we have
another that's pretty interesting what
if the Avengers assembled in 16002 this
is episode 8 coming out December 29th
and according to The Insider can we get
some toast this wha if episode is a band
of marry men the marry men are Robin
Hood's group who work to rob from the
rich and give to the poor and according
to can we get some toast the Avengers of
16002 are going to be Steve Rogers Bucky
Barnes and Scott Lang also featured are
blacksmith Tony Stark and a purple Hulk
happy Hogan which I am totally down to
see I think this is going to be a funny
episode then for the last episode
episode 9 on December 30th gets really
interesting because it's titled what if
strange Supreme intervened and we are
assuming this is kind of going to pick
up from the story of what if season 1
which is a big surprise that the two are
actually going to be connected and there
is some type of continuity between the
two and now people are wondering if
there is actually going to be sort of a
crossover between the whatif universe
and the liveaction Marvel Universe since
the Multiverse is in play right now let
us know what you think about that in the
comments down below now according to The
Insider cryptic HD quality episode 1 is
31 minutes long episode 2 is 31 minutes
long episode 3 3 is 30 minutes and
episode 4 is 34 minutes unfortunately
those are the only times that we have
right now for those specific four
episodes but what if season 2 should be
fun go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about it in the comments down
below are you excited are you watching
or not don't forget to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things MCU and please
don't forget to give the video a like
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof